good morning Johnny yes I do folks good
morning to you I know there's been some
frustrations but we're here to bring you
a little bit of holiday cheer we've
heard that there's been a number of
flights and delayed and canceled we're
hearing about parking also being closed
out because it's that busy but again
we're going to try to bring you some
holiday cheer up someone special with me
for that Santa thank you so much for
joining us are you excited about your
travel oh yes I can't wait to start
driving around the world tomorrow lots
of awesome okay and we have some people
here with us that we'll be traveling we
gave him some candy a little bit earlier
Merry Christmas you guys tell us your
name really quickly and where you guys
going hey my name is Corey sinking we're
traveling home for the holidays in
Fairfield California okay okay and how's
the travel going so far it's been great
we were here for a basketball tournament
it went well we ready to get home and
just do Christmas together awesome well
good luck and happy holidays bye lovely
and you guys are going somewhere as well
did you guys get just get to the airport
yes okay and tell me your names really
quickly I'm Elijah and yours I'm Faith
nice to meet you guys okay where you
guys headed uh Oakland California okay
how's the travel been so far pretty good
okay yeah you guys have fun and be safe
as well here's some candy for you too
we're trying to make it easier for
people we've seen that there's 77
flights delayed 104 canceled here at the
airport as we mentioned parking is
closed so I do have Joe Rachel with me
here to tell us a little bit more about
what people can expect tell us a little
bit about the parking yeah good morning
so we've seen already this morning the
terminal one long-term garage has
reached capacity and is closed and I
just got notification that the terminal
3 economy lot has also reached capacity
in his clothes we kind of expect that to
be the case throughout the day so we
recommend people give themselves a
little bit of extra time to find parking
and head straight to the terminal 3
long-term parking garage we know there's
parking over there they can either catch
a shuttle back to terminal one if they
need to or they can just go through the
checkpoint at terminal three so
hopefully they'll be able to find some
quick parking spots okay do you expect
to get a little bit slower after that
goes on or busier no I would say we're
probably going to see a busier day here
as it continues people getting off of
work maybe taking half days and then
traveling here for this uh Christmas
weekend all right Joe well you go enjoy
your holidays we appreciate you chatting
with us this morning giving us those
tips here are a few additional tips now
if you do have a gift don't wrap it
it'll be easier for you to get through
security and you don't want them to
unwrap your gift as well as that make
sure you bring extra supplies with you
extra food clothes medicine all of these
good things just in case you get stuck
like some of the folks here in the
airport and again we'll be here giving
out some candy of course you lovely
family as you guys go on your travel
safe travels enjoy and of course
spending time with Santa okay Santa
that's how you have some gifts for me
really quickly what is this this is a
peekaboo elf okay and it's a it's a
great elf that you can sleep with and
cuddle with and tell all your dreams
awesome thank you so much it's because
I've been an amazing elf have fun Santa
be safe out there on your safe travels
don't forget his keys he has some
cookies for us back at the station guys
so nice for now live from Harry the
international I'm Candace Charles
Arkansas class eight news now
all right Canada